this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends I have benefited from
therapy for a very long time and it
helps me with my mental Clarity so I
want you to try to and try it with
better help better help connect you with
the licensed therapist who can take you
on that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are super convenient and
that's what I love about them the most
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief question
there to get matched with the licensed
therapist and switch therapist anytime
for no additional charge discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius to get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp help
help.com genius everything's an
extension of my art shut the [__] up
just be like dog I was I was in a mental
institution I lost my mind I was afraid
that I couldn't
um one up my past stories like my my
personality was tied to this podcast and
I thought I was going to lose viewers so
I just kept lying like a piece of [__]
that's a [__] apology that makes more
sense that makes more sense in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast I am your host David so we
have my reoccurring co-host Ed Park
what's up Ed parkvp back from Seattle
after a whole month of [__]
debauchery
yeah no there wasn't much going on at
all how was it oh it was rough to be
honest
it was rough dog the
the first like day after like I was
watching the store I came in early in
the morning and then there were these
like three little white kids like five
to ten years old they were getting
snacks and um ice cream and stuff and
then I came out of the back from
stocking beer
and this little white kid sees me and he
points at me and he goes China
Jesus Christ is this your first day back
one day one bro
and then like the next day one employee
[__] just disappeared
like she just was a no-show didn't pick
up her phone for a week then I get hit
back up like oh I was in a car accident
I totaled my car so I didn't my I didn't
have my phone my phone was in my car
like all week
okay she's like I was in the hospital
and and then so I went to go meet up
with her
she looked fine and I'm not taking
anything away from her but then one of
them boys later said hey I just saw her
driving around in her totaled car quote
unquote dog dude
and then they told me she's an alcoholic
she kind of shows up drunk but she lives
like 40 minutes away but took a job at
our gas station because she's stalking
her ex-boyfriend at the bar and grill
across the street so they broke up and
she had a restraining order and so to
get closer to him she got a job at her
store how come there just isn't a normal
day in your life at that [__] store
man it's cursed dude
let me tell you something you know
what's so funny like
I've been trying to like find people to
work with right specifically out in
Hawaii with our store right and
everybody that we have now is great all
the employees there are a [__]
fantastic Joe Raves about them says
they're amazing that's great well I'm
trying to find other people for other
tests outside of the store right
can somebody in Hawaii explain to me why
the [__] everybody's excuse for not
showing up is the two same excuses I've
gotten it five times right by five
different people
I have kobit and then my kid took my
phone man you know that you know that
sickness going around you know where
kids are kleptomaniacs
and I'm like and I'm not making this
[__] up and I'm just sitting here like
am I your parent you know what I mean
yeah are you am I going to spank you
you're a [__] adult yeah just say you
didn't either pick up your phone or you
didn't read the email and you're sorry
that's it like the first time I was like
okay maybe right let me tell you the
first time so when we were in Hawaii
there was this we were looking for
storage and there was a storage that was
kind of near our store that we so we hit
this guy up two months before yeah right
because we have to plan out everything
this is before the store was opened
everything was chaotic we needed to find
storage so we could store basically all
of our stuff in bulk so it's a lot
cheaper for us we need to get that done
first we hit this guy up we're
communicating back and forth we get to
the island the guy doesn't pick up we we
get to the we get to the storage area we
talked to the front person the security
they have uh like this alternate number
that they have or whatever they could
reach them for emergencies hits them up
[__] just starts stuttering and
guess what he says oh my my kid uh has
my phone and then I have covered
and I'm like bro I'm not your parent
what the [__] are you talking about guy
you don't have to like lie about this
right now
what happened man what happens he forgot
yeah he [__] forgot just like
everybody else forgot but then if he
said hey man I'm sorry I forgot that's
way more acceptable it's not like I'm
it's not excusable but it's more
acceptable like these weird excuses hey
man so somebody came through the door
and then the [__] an eagle came and
smashed my phone and I was looking for
this Eagle for [__] three weeks I was
trying to jump over a puddle and my
phone fell and have you heard of these
things called the mentors
I walk through this [__] Gateway was
a brick wall into another University
like where's my phone like bro come on
but this happens a lot with um I don't
know like what it is it's I don't know
like how old were they this guy's oldest
[__] he owns the [__] storage oh okay
it's a grown [__] man like I I just
don't understand how adults use that
excuse like how dare you [__] throw
your kids under the bus like my [__]
kids [__] terrible parents because
you don't know his kids
I know it's all true and then you just
say yeah kids are [__] stupid and
he's like don't talk about my kids
dog you know what's funny um
so the other day uh I I took a nap
um I was super tired woke up and then I
looked at my phone
I look at my phone
and my Instagram
has like 30k plus followers what I'm
like what the [__] would you do I didn't
do anything I I don't post that
regularly right so I was kind of sitting
on it looking at her I was like whatever
you know
it's it's maybe it's like a glitch and
then it's gonna fix itself because I've
been losing [__] followers on
Instagram every time I post for some
reason people are reminded that they
hate me
I [__] hate this fat [__] and they
[__] unfollow me so
it's like that's been the typical thing
that's been happening yeah so apparently
one of my videos that I made in February
it got in the hands of a lot of people
and they just started sharing it right
it's this video where this lady has like
this child that looks like a Chucky doll
and so it blew up right that the
Instagram algorithm algorithm is weird
where it will just show up in your
Explorer page or like it's all sprawling
yeah it doesn't matter when it but for
some reason some some people got a hand
of it probably who had a following they
shared it and it just kind of
steamrolled from there uh and I only
found out because somebody told me
because I just didn't know I couldn't
for some reason I didn't think that it
would be old content that would cause
this to happen yeah and then they showed
me the look at the video see how many
views it has it has [__] like 12
million views what the [__] yeah it's
like it just took a while it just
somebody found it and it just kind of
went went crazy let's take a moment to
thank our Lord and savior algorithm
you know when I so I was talking to
Mario about this and she goes well how
do you feel about it I was like you know
it doesn't feel like anything and I I
went back to thinking about the first
time when I was on YouTube
and
um UCLA girl the UCLA when the video
popped off and I remember feeling like
my whole world was spinning because I
couldn't fathom that this video reached
x amount of people yeah it was like
millions of views like two million views
in a matter of like a couple of weeks
and just thinking about that made me
feel like oh this is insane and now you
have this video that did you know 10x
the numbers and I look at it and I go
hmm right yeah because what's the uh
been there I've been there and like
what's the next step from this like what
do I do from here do I what do I like I
don't know if you were an impressionable
gen Z kid where the algorithm blesses
you and then you get 10 million views on
some stupid ass video where you do you
know some dance or some [__] right yeah
then what happens to them man like it
gets into their head and all that [__]
that they're not prepared for it let me
tell you something it was very
interesting and this happened before too
so years ago I didn't know that there
was that 99 plus request box right right
so there was a bunch of there was like
K-pop people who were hitting me up like
because they were they saw my book
videos were very funny yeah and I see
and then Tim was the one who let me know
that you have to hit that 99 plus
request and then you could filter
through you know these top requests and
it was like the who's who it's like yo
we should work together and then you
know it's been 2018 dude it's like three
four years and I go what's up bro I hope
you see this yeah and you're gonna end
up in their requests
so there was a couple of people not
gonna say their names but who I hit them
up was like Hey I I just figured out
this thing you know my buddy Tim told me
because of this T-Pain thing that went
around where T-Pain didn't know right
right and was laughing about that and I
was laughing too but I didn't know what
they meant yeah and I was like oh oh I'm
one of those [__] too and hit them up
and then you know there's a couple of
people who when they respond to you
they'll hit you up right they'll hit you
up again and then on the third one it's
not cordial anymore they're like like
what's up you're not gonna hit me back
up but you too good for me and I'm like
you were talking to nobody for three
years yeah
what the [__] are you talking about like
I didn't see it yeah I didn't [__]
see it and even if I did see it per se I
don't know you you know what I mean and
so like I was looking through some of
these messages a while back and I went
like the [__] audacity you're here
having an argument with literally nobody
oh man the
expectations and that's something I'm
working on managing my expectations but
also
the entitlement of some people
they you owe them a [__] reply yeah
it's that check mark next to them now I
understand why on Twitter not you know
the Twitter check mark is gone why
people are freaking the [__] out right
every [__] tweet was oh I'm not gonna
pay for this oh the reason why I'm
paying for this is because of this they
had to justify it I saw that who the
[__] cares who cares but for a lot of
people that verification shows that hey
I'm worthy yeah I am worth something
well that's what it used to be yeah well
now you have to pay for it because I
have to pay for it but then it actually
is a useful metric now right once you
pay for it your engagement goes up by
the thousands a lot and you're like the
top replier to some other famous persons
or blue checks they make it kind of
worth it right so you know they're
they're tapping into like human
psychology or now like the benefit of it
isn't so much because a lot of people
say it's because of oh I get to edit my
tweets that's why I'm keeping it I'm
doing it for my business yeah sure no no
you're doing it so you can get seen more
yeah it's for that level of importance
and I understand like on a business
aspect everything else like that but
most people they're not doing this for
business they're doing it for other
reasons and so when I was sitting there
and thinking about it I explained on my
Instagram just once again just to
respond to some of these people because
I wasn't going to direct DM them and
argue with them it's just you know
listen I'm doing this for fun you know
this is for fun like I have the stuff I
do for money Instagram is for fun if
business happens to come out of it then
it will but the idea that you go from hi
hello what's going on yeah you [__]
[__] it's like you don't even have my
actual phone number
what am I your friend yeah you know what
I mean but it's like oh it starts
texting 9-1-1 9-1-1 call me yeah but
when the whole thing kind of blew up it
was such a weird moment where I kind of
thought to myself of like yeah not that
I'm like I'm not you know quote-unquote
done with this space is what I'm saying
but it feels different now right now
like this thing when I was younger it
was kind of tied to how I felt about my
level of success yeah and I don't have
that anymore now it's just oh I'm glad
people laughed like I'm glad I made
people laugh and then I just moved the
[__] on because I remember when my video
first popped off on YouTube the first
thing that I did was like okay I need to
make more videos more videos I need to
make them twice a week three times a
week people need to see this stuff I
need to have a set schedule people need
to know when I'm gonna upload and I was
so just just so into it you know what I
mean everything it was everything to me
yeah
and it's not to say that
um I'm not grateful for the things that
I have now it's just now my motivation
is very different like the idea well
because also at the time I was so
[__] poor like I had no [__] money
yeah I like my dream was to you know
become a comedian you know you know
carve my name out into space and now
that I've done that you know how we're
small or big that maybe people may think
that it is now I can you know do other
things so it was kind of interesting
watching how I reacted to that because I
mean you feel like
it's the other noise the noise other
people are making on you because you
don't
follow in line with the rest of them and
by that I mean like because they haven't
set their expectations on you
I feel like everybody else assumes
you're on the same hustle and purpose
that they are that they're the reasons
they're doing it is your reasons because
the you know you network in La you find
other people like you and the reason why
you want to be an actor or get into
entertainment and such yeah but you have
a completely different reason than the
rest of the plot yeah and maybe those
voices are are coming at you but they
just don't know like hey this is a hobby
for me at this point yeah like I'm doing
it for fun like can you imagine somebody
in a sport like who knows let's just say
MMA because we like MMA but they just
come in like I'm just doing this for fun
then all the other Fighters might be
like you [__] [__] like I need
this bonus yeah I need this uh Bobby
green you see how [__] pissed yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he was pissed about
his win money yeah the win bonus and so
for someone to come in and be like
nonchalant like ah it's for fun man wins
and losses you're like bro you don't
live it like I do but it's like well
then that's you yeah you live the way
that you want like I do want people to
understand that some people are
motivated differently than you right and
just because they don't have your same
motivations doesn't mean that they think
that they're better than you doesn't
think that I'm like I'm on some elevated
level it's just I just having fun
you know I mean just to have a fun you
know what that's it every day I just
have fun you know and I think it bothers
people like how come you're not doing
this like me yeah it's like because you
I have a father
but it's nice it's a bit of nice you
know like I enjoy and I understand what
it's like to be in the rat race and
let me let me let me so uh I was hanging
out with her with our buddy Robin right
and I got to meet one of his friends
very successful guy and we were
up all night just chopping it up but
um
talking to his friend like reminded me
of
why I do what I do and why I chose to
stay here right because his friend
very successful guy makes a lot of money
recently quit his job that's why he was
kicking with us kicking it with us to
like 1am yeah and
um he got to a point in his life and
hearing the story reaffirm what I what I
choose to do and why I am the way that I
am and he's typically known as a
workaholic uh non-stop working doesn't
really matter he I think he said he was
traveling like 200 plus days out of the
year for the last like x amount of years
he's been working at his job yeah so WWE
wrestler
Triple H came by yeah
and when he said goodbye
busy schedule the year man he [__]
gave me the pedigree wow but um he
travels so often because um he's like a
designer and he does like Tech stuff so
he gets flown out everywhere and he's
like the head guy
um one day he was working and they asked
him to go somewhere else right it was
like short notice stuff like it always
is and then he just stopped and he went
no
he snapped the hell he had a moment
where he goes
I'm not doing this he has a wife he's
about to have a kid on the way and then
he had this moment where just in that I
guess whatever happened in between and
there's other details I don't want to
say because obviously it's his personal
life even though you guys don't know him
I don't feel comfortable talking about
it but there was that and a few other
things that had him in this moment where
he goes this is not important anymore
and then his boss basically he's so
important to the company his boss was
like Hey listen I understand like you're
stressed you're overworked but how about
this
take a whole year off
full paid salary benefits
everything
bonus whatever you name it hold your off
spend time with your family and then did
you just come back so that whole year he
would make the same amount of money but
just wouldn't work at all yeah and he
goes I quit
Jerry Maguire over here dude I quit he
leaves
and because he figured out what was
important to him because he had enough
he had enough he had what he had so when
you go back to thinking about the fact
that your Vibe your video went viral
again it's like I've done this I've had
enough yeah it feels the the
satisfaction that I get from it is that
I'm glad people are laughing it's not
damn look at these numbers people know
who I am it's
damn I made somebody laugh yeah and
that's what that's the part that feels
good that's enough for me it fills my
cup it's essentially what it was for and
why you do it in the first place right
not because I need the numbers but hey
500 people like this video and is that
enough for you some people it's not yeah
it's enough for them to delete the video
it's it's crazy right like I've
like what I used to do when I first
started it out I started out on
Instagram because you have the ability
to hide your likes right and I started
hiding likes because uh I was told that
it's good for brand deals like just hide
your likes but then I was doing it a lot
and then the last few months I was like
the [__] this [__] do you [__] this [__]
all this [__] you know if people don't
[__] like the food
Affairs you know what I mean leave the
likes it is what it is it's honest
because I have to be about the [__] that
I say like if I truly say like none of
this really matters and you should be
happy with the content that you put out
just because you put it out then I got
to be true to that [__] I can't be a
little [__] about it so is it important
to you
to be able to see the dislikes on
YouTube
you know the dislikes never bothered me
so
that's not true when I first started
this likes bothered me yeah for everyone
it was a thumbs down on Instagram
my poor heart
I know people if there was a dislike on
[__] Instagram they would cry
themselves asleep yeah dude and I know
look
I like I know people who constantly
rewrite their Instagram post just to
make sure they don't offend absolutely
anybody they they do review after review
after review they get one comment like
oh I don't think this is correct they
respond to them in paragraphs yeah let
me explain to you why I am so sorry I
made you feel this way but like first of
all shut the [__] up who the [__] cares
you don't know this person you don't
like you don't know where they're from
you don't know where they are you don't
know what they're like you don't know
what they look like you don't owe them
[__] anything and look
uh there's there's um
there's a a comedian named Jordan
female comic right I think she's [__]
hilarious like I I love following on
Instagram because watching her just riff
with the crowd has me in tears laughing
sometimes just because how crazy smart
she is so she put a post recently where
she did a bit about people like down
syndrome right which is very hard to do
yeah you know what I mean yeah but I
thought that she did it really well and
it was [__] hilarious yeah but
obviously there's a few people who are
like listen you know what when it comes
to Comedy you went way too far and
sometimes with comedy when I when I look
at this stuff I actually didn't think it
was too far I thought it was done very
well like because the the classic saying
that people love saying is oh you're
punching down I [__] hate that phrase
now like it used to be something I
understood and now everybody just uses
it for [__] everything
the problem with that is that sometimes
when people talk about like comedy in
that type of way it just like where does
it end right because you found it
completely okay when she was talking
about I don't know like um her lesbian
moms or whatever whatnot right and how
weird that situation was or what I
talked about when my parents beat my ass
and I got abused which is child abuse
laughing your ass off so why is that
okay
um right so why is this one
okay right it's just like I like I don't
know I think like I do understand that
there are certain things that are done
very distastefully there's a line that
people won't cross right and that's like
you don't touch it right but then if
it's something that you can
do mindfully then it could be a genius
that's the part of the craft yeah that's
what makes comedy so great you know
which you know a lot of comics talk
about this now and I've said it too a
million times over so much comedy now
has gotten watered down like I see so
many specials on Netflix where
everything's a TED talk you know what I
mean I think it's like Chappelle did it
so yeah but Chappelle does it but he has
punch lines yeah and he's a masterful
Storyteller exactly yeah crying laughing
I'm like where the [__] is the punchline
in this [__] yeah and everybody who does
like mediocre comedy is just getting I'm
so proud that you're brave enough to go
up there that's not enough yeah it's
just it's mediocrity yeah right and like
I'm like I'm not a great stem comic so I
know what it's like to be sucky
you know but the idea that sucky stand
up makes me feel that I could go up
there too it's terrible like I shouldn't
feel that way yeah you know and but like
watching her kind of like this girl
Jordan I thought she did a taste but I
read these lines and people are just
some people obviously there's a few that
are like I can't believe you would do a
joke on this and then other people are
ripping into that comment like I don't
understand where your morality is here
yeah I think people should
you know open up a space in their minds
where joking about something helps
normalize it
right so you're humanizing it as well
you know especially like when you are
making jokes about Down syndrome that
you are humanizing it and opening it up
to people or when you make autistic
jokes because we have autistic friends
or people are autistic if you can do it
to a point where they are with you on
then it's gonna be money have you seen
that clip of Andrew Santino making fun
of Bobby's mom
and over
a Korean yeah I [__] love Andrew
Santos what's he doing racist
impressions of a Korean woman
like
[Laughter]
but man like everybody gets it like
every I don't mean like everyone gets it
everyone gets a joke everyone's going to
get it yeah everyone's gonna get roasted
you can't just build up this wall this
invisible wall because people can punch
right through it anyway the only other
thing you can do is block your ears or
just get off the [__] internet yeah
and you know you're allowed not to think
that it's funny yeah but the idea that
you want to cancel this person because
it specifically offended you doesn't
really make sense like like I said there
are Asian jokes out there that are so
distasteful it's clearly just racial you
know what I mean like there's no funny
Nuance to it we're not included in the
joke right like the the Andrew Santino
was so ridiculous right and also because
Bobby and him have a friendship yeah
that makes it funny yeah you know what I
mean it's just so on the edge like it's
not okay but Bobby's laughing his
[__] [__]
or something yeah yeah so it makes sense
you know what I mean
um this is actually a good segue so a
lot of people have been asking us to do
a review on
um beef it's like the most requested be
most requested right uh
you know and I and I wrote to people in
the comments that you know give us time
because it came out for like two days
and they go where's our review like hey
I'm glad you like the reviews two days
yes that's all you're giving me there
are 10 episodes of this [__] you know
what I mean I think people are just so
used to this binge culture like they
just saw it they just spent 10 hours on
it you know that's why like I even watch
people who do
um reels and they do this is my movie
review in a real damn
how do you do a movie review in a
[__] reel are you insane that makes
no sense to me it's ridiculous so it's
like not even fair yeah it's not fair to
the film yeah so I was like look yo just
give give me some [__] time let me
watch this [__] I got two more episodes
left yeah right I've been slow playing
it a little bit I have other things
going on and guess what after I watched
it the first time guess what I'm gonna
do again watch it again I'll watch it
again so it's gonna take a little bit of
times but you know before we do a review
on beef this episode isn't going to be a
review on beef there is something that I
do want to address before we go into
that because it's not something that I
could really look over yeah so when I
was about like six episodes in
this controversy about David Cho comes
up yeah right
um if you guys watch beef David Cho is
the artist he's very well known for the
huge come-up that he had for pain for
for Facebook right so during that time
David chill was an artist he was going
through a lot of financial [__]
um I think he was he just got out of
jail and then Facebook hit him up saying
like hey we want you to do this this
mural it was one of the one of the top
exacts at Facebook and
um
prior to all this he was like look I'm
I'm you don't know this but I'm gonna
get you get one of your artworks in my
building so they want he wanted him to
do murals all over the Facebook building
or or headquarters it was like five
months old at that time exactly yeah and
so
it was like sixty thousand dollars and
he goes 2005 right yeah he goes yeah
sixty thousand dollars fine or you could
take stock right
David chose a gambler yeah he goes I'll
just take the stock even though he was
hurting for money apparently he was in
debt he owed people money but he decided
to take that instead
well good bet because he made hundreds
of millions of dollars over estimated
over 250 million crazy doesn't really
have to work again right and um people
kind of know David Cho for his insane
personality he has a lot of crazy
stories I was actually first introduced
to some of his stories because I
actually wasn't an avid listener of DVD
ASA so if you guys don't know what dvdos
is this was a podcast that he did and
this is where the drama comes from
you'll see familiar faces like Stevie
weebie was on there uh also Bobby Lee
was that was one of his first podcast
appearances there Bobby Lee got a whole
like host of characters on his show like
I was an avid listener DVD ASA that's
how he said it but it's double veg
double anal sensitive artist that's what
it stands for that's rasa Kira
yeah the idea was oh it's David and ASA
but he's like nope double batch double
Angel sensitive artist because he's into
weird random [__] like part of his art
isn't just murals he sells these giant
blankets and ponchos right it's a
[__] [__] it's a sphincter it's
the spiral of like you don't know what
it is right because it's so close up and
it's a giant backup you back up and look
at it that's a [__] [__] that's
hilarious and he's been posting it all
over social media on Instagram for years
people don't get it it might be his
[__] so that's who David Cho is he's
not just like oh he paints really well
his mind
is something else he's a very very
interesting character and I didn't
really know too much about him and my
first real introduction to kind of who
he is as a person was actually listening
to him on a Joe Rogan podcast yeah where
I got to hear him hunt for dinosaurs in
the Congo or Amazon and I'm like this
guy is [__] crazy yeah he's a [__]
crazy person he's talking about and even
the way that he speaks he almost seems
like he's having like a an outer body
experience or he's like schizophrenic
almost yeah okay David you need to calm
down okay you can't say that I'm like
who the [__] is he talking he's talking
to himself out loud on a podcast this
guy's [__] nuts yeah
um
and so having a little bit of background
in this and you know I decided to you
know listen to the audio right of of
what was going on and we're gonna
actually listen to it right now just to
give you guys a little context
I mean it's
I guess you should put up a trigger
warning for sure because it's oh it's
going to be on there yeah so there was a
few audio pieces that people took right
I don't know where they're getting this
from because I don't know where to
listen to this podcast so this means
people had this in the [__] bag
somewhere or people who are really big
fans or whatever recorded this for the
for their later listening or whatever
um so this is the clip that they're that
they're talking about that's what
achieved the erection Quest the getting
the thing so you're basically telling us
that you're a rapist now and the only
way to get your dick really hard is rape
yeah what does she look like
half black half white
um long curly hair
um how old big titties
huge titties what the [__] is wrong with
you guys huge real titties who cares
what she looks like Dave is telling us
he's a rapist
look like how long was her hair a
successful rapist so this is actually
the video clip where he talks about what
he did to this masseuse that was a
little intro to it and this is actually
from I grabbed this from tick tock
and it's not it's just like she's just
like holding it like limp no she's
holding it but she's just like she's
holding it on her own yeah okay and I go
you like that and she's like yeah it's
all right
like she's not like yeah I love it she's
like it's it's okay
and I was like can you you know help me
out a little bit and so she does it but
a little hot but it's horrible it's like
this
she's not doing it you know she's still
in denial she's in denial so I go can I
help you
and um she's like
all right all right so then I put my
hand over her hand and I put my other
hand and I go so now I'm holding her
hand around like yes and I start jerking
my dick off and she's like in one of her
strands of her hair goes down and I'm
like and I go this is how I like it and
she's like oh and I was like I was like
spit on it and she's like uh no I don't
want to do that and I was like no spit
on my dick and she's like no she's like
this is this is crazy you know and it's
like she's definitely like not into like
into it but she's not stopping it either
because she doesn't know yet she doesn't
know yet yeah she doesn't know because
in her head I think she's thinking I'm
gonna get a good tip oh well I'll tell
you what happened with that so then so
then I say spit on it she won't spit on
it and then and then I was like I was
like kiss it and she's like no there's
all the oil there's what's wrong with
you there's like
he has a problem this is the difference
between asking so I say I go kiss it a
little she's like no all the massage
rooms on it I take the back of her head
and I push it down on my dick and she
doesn't do it and then I go open your
mouth open your mouth and she does it
and then I start face [__] her you
raped
well okay I'm gonna tell you my first
reaction when I saw this so you know
when you read headlines you kind of take
everything with the grain of salt
because you don't know what people are
talking about if they're exaggerating
when I heard that [__] my blood started
to boil a little bit yeah um I don't get
triggered like this because you know
when people who are podcasters or you
know people who think that they're funny
David Cho is not a comedian and I don't
think he's funny at all
um I think he's a weird interesting
person right I heard that [__] that
actually I I start getting pissed yeah
um specifically because I saw um it was
a comic in there like Danny Joe he's
[__] hilarious hates me but he's
hilarious
um but Danny Cho and Stevie's there and
you can look at their face and they look
mortified
I don't know if that's Danny chill is it
I think that is no I think it's his
friend he's this Japanese dude who's
like his accountant as well oh really it
looks like it's not it's not that's
crazy
okay so
my bad hilarious either way he's [__]
funny ass comic
um but it's him and then Stephen you
look at their face they look mortified
they're just kind of like huh because
I'm trying to process this right like
number one and I was talking about this
off podcast I was not an avid listener
of this podcast so I don't know what his
personality is like so when I see this
clip I can only take it for face value
for what it is and you know the idea
behind this is that you know he put out
a statement later on saying like listen
I hate rapists I think all rapists
should be killed and the idea that
people are saying that I'm a rapist
makes me sick
um
and he says that the thing that I'm
guilty of the most is you know being a
bad storyteller
and that that pissed me off you know the
apology pissed me off because
if you're saying that you're a b the
only thing you can be accused of is of
being a bad Storyteller then it still
happened yeah so I don't understand the
what he's trying to say or what he's
trying to communicate here and you know
for me I don't want to excuse this type
of behavior right as a comic as people
who are podcasters people who entertain
people through stories sometimes they'll
say [__] and they'll exaggerate things
right so they'll take something that's
truthful and they'll kind of expand on
it of course all of us Comics do it
right 80 truth 20 embellishment yeah if
this is 80 truth still trash yeah so I'm
trying to process what the [__] is this
guy [__] talking about yeah and he's
talking about this and I'm kind of like
trying to hear the lie in it right
because it seems like he's compounding
on the story well what he's claiming is
that it's all alive from the jump all of
it is alive damn I don't know man that's
really hard for me so like like for me
like I'm I'm still
when I process it is like the timeline
of everything for him right like I take
a step back at the 30 000 feet act like
I'm an alien in a spaceship and
observance yeah yeah right that's the
best way for me to kind of process
things and
um just putting it in a timeline like
this was like
a long time ago for him right because he
told that story in 2014 and at that
point he was like 38 something years old
or 39 years old yeah so this story is
even further ago or something
and then like
at that time there were like three
podcasts that were pretty big ish to me
with that I was listening to it was
Kevin Smith Joe Rogan and DVD ASA okay
right and the three things that these
podcasts have in common was they were
saying anything and everything like the
way Kevin Smith would talk about comic
book [__] was the way you would never
hear it because comic book [__] you had
to say it cleanly yeah but he would say
[__] about you know how like you know uh
just
I don't know I think you wouldn't think
about like
um workers comp for the people who died
on the [__] death star and [__] you
know all these things like Joe Rogan
also talked about random [__] you just
wouldn't hear on mainstream [__] but
David was he was on he featured on Kevin
Smith's podcast I think once and Kevin
Smith was on dvdasa David Cho went on
Joe Rogan Kevin Smith went on Joe Rogan
you know so they were kind of like uh
all the podcasters at the time were
doing their thing together but with
David Cho what I recall clearly is he
kept trying to tell the most [__] up
stories like the craziest stories right
that's for some of us it's like we all
the stories I've been telling like I've
experienced a lot of crazy things right
but for him he was saying that
um he ran out of crazy stories and they
started making [__] up
and so I thought he's saying at that
point that like they were just thinking
okay what's the next most [__] up
thing we can think of
and after he told that and released that
episode and then he was being flamed he
the next week he went on Joe Rogan in
2014 and he said specifically about that
episode about what he was saying he's
saying I made it up I made it all up and
he apologized then too
the apology apology you're talking about
he it's a repeat apology from 2017
because he did a mural in Manhattan and
as soon as it was finished someone
tagged rapist on it and then painting oh
[__] yeah and so he took a picture of it
and was like this thing came up again
and then he gave that second apology to
mention once again I made it all up
because of this right and at that point
this podcast is brought to you by
betterhelp my lovely genius brain
listeners if you haven't tried online
therapy start with better help getting
to know yourself can be a lifelong
process especially because we're always
growing and changing the person you were
the day before it's not going to be the
person you are tomorrow so focus on the
person you are today with an online
therapist it's very cathartic if you're
thinking about starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
deciding to be convenient a flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
the licensed therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge my friends better help has been a
part of my life for a very long time now
so give it a go you have nothing to lose
and guess what mental Clarity will help
you out because 2023 is your Year my
friend so make sure you focus on you
discover your potential with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com genius today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com genius
it for us as the public because he's a
public figure and we're the audience
it's up to us to now like do where we
decide like like what's real he's
telling the truth or he's [__] lying
right and then at the same time for me
it's like
do I have to make a decision because I
don't know this [__] yeah it's
not a part of my life and nothing he
ever does affects my life yeah except
not people will might want to say I'm
not watching beef now because of this
yeah because he is a guest star in it
you know yeah he didn't produce it he
was an actor in it yeah but that's for
me what's the weird thing is that
I think what they're the the public is
mad about they're mad at Steven Yoon
and Ali Wong forecasting it for casting
because they knew about this as they
knew about it or some [__] and then hey
you hired him anyway so that's the thing
about now that's cancel culture coming
back out of man who apologized for all
these things right now here's the thing
you don't have to accept the apology
right because it's at that point whether
you believe him or not
now there's a guy named Yoshi who used
to be on the show he's a Korean
but ethically Korean Japanese is that
guy
huh he was that guy that thought was
Danny Cho uh no no it's another guy oh
okay he left the show because he he had
beef with David Cho they used to be
close they they went on Joe Rogan
together oh [__] and they were telling
[__] up crazy stories his name is
yoshiobayashi
so yeah ethnically Korean Japanese who
immigrated to Tacoma Washington right
and
he like had a [__] up time there in
Tacoma got massively bullied not only by
just white and black people out in
Tacoma but at church at the Korean
church he went to because he was so such
thick Japanese accent and he didn't
speak Korean
and so he got bullied by everyone oh
[__] so he has these crazy stories too
and then so they started DVDs together
it started telling crazy stories because
this guy was a video editor right guess
where at Vivid Entertainment so he was
hilarious he was editing transporn yeah
back in the day and so they just had all
these crazy [__] up stories about
their lives but the reason why he left
the show and he started his own podcast
and the first one like every episode he
gets where he brings it up is how much
he doesn't like David not because of
this incident but because he's a liar
because he makes up all these stories
because he embellishes Yoshi's own
stories too to make feels crazier yeah
and steals it because he needed content
for the podcast that actually makes me
hate David Cho even more because he's an
artist yeah like the idea that you're
stealing somebody else's story and
saying that yours makes him even trash
and well it wasn't saying that this is
his story because but it happened Yoshi
he would tell Yoshi's stories but make
him crazier embellish them where Yoshi's
like can you just keep it real like
shit's crazy when it's crazy yeah and
shit's normal when it's normal so he's a
phony
it was a show for him it was a show of
just exaggerating it because I
understand too like I said when we tell
stories like we we tell the story to
make it as entertaining entertaining as
possible but the facts are still there
like if I tell a story about something
that happened from my hometown
it's pretty much all the same like what
happened happened right but the name
like I said well I changed the names the
area will be different because obviously
I'm being careful about and I've said
this million times before about it's not
going back to people right because I'm
trying to be mindful right and that's
really about it but the heart of the
story is it's true and with 80 of it's
there yeah like there's no like oh it
it's just like it's very convincing yeah
it's very very convincing to be in a
completely fake story yeah but even to
this day even like look I'm not trying
to excuse this guy like like and I even
hate the term Devil's Advocate I'm
trying to give the big picture here
about this guy and his behavior yeah
because he's also admittedly has issues
for the last three years he was saying
he was in a mental hospital yeah since
that incident he went to a mental
hospital for three years yeah yeah which
doesn't really help his case either
because I could see somebody who's in
the middle house raping somebody yeah do
you know like
like as he's telling that story like the
part that really you know I was first
listening to like what's going on and
then you know it went from my eyes going
wide to getting pissed when he was like
the part where he said open your mouth
and I got [__] heated dude like I got
pissed rightfully so because it's the
whole idea of like people who
you know even the guys who were laughing
in the video about rape culture yeah you
know like the perpetuation of it like
the only person there is asakira who's
like what the [__] you guys yeah right
and like
because I saw the stuff about Stephen
Yoon right and I think like he was
telling a similar story about some
something about sexual assault right and
you hear Steven you laugh
um
and I'm not excusing that at all but
like I said a lot of people tend to
think that they're a lot braver than
they are in these situations when you're
kind of in a room with somebody who is
bigger than life and they start telling
ridiculous [__] yeah most likely I would
say like 90 of people aren't going to be
like what the [__] are you saying what
are you doing you're going to awkwardly
laugh and then kind of try to process
what the [__] just happened you know
what I mean especially because he's the
boss it says show exactly what are you
gonna do interrupt the show like only it
seems like Assa felt like the only one
in power to do that exactly because Asa
didn't give a [__] right and you know I
heard the audio that they mentioned of
like Steven Yoon kind of like laughing
which I think I do have it let me see if
I can find it
because I do want to give people kind of
context um so you guys can decide for
yourself right like what the [__] like
there was a scene where you and your
girlfriend on the show get captured at
the same time and you're in the Next
Room
like I forgot the exact uh [__] I should
have originally should have been
listening like you're gonna are
potentially getting raped yeah exactly I
mean that is yeah my number one jerk off
fantasy damn so I'm not about that
like that was his father I was like wait
what's the fantasy you hearing your
girlfriend get raped well let's support
a girl in to say it happened in real
life so I tied myself up and I can't
move and then I call someone to come
rape my girlfriend oh you're a couple
yeah I called myself damn that makes my
stomach curl and look whatever you guys
want to joke about with your friends and
your little circle group however sick it
is I don't have to hear it you know so I
don't know it's it's absurd you know
what I mean like
so because he has done it so many times
this is why I don't like there's a lot
of evidence like that you're giving me
right now that makes me feel like yeah
this is probably 100 made up but he
keeps going back to this well multiple
times and people have recordings of him
talking about rape so much it's like
how much do I believe this is fake No
like is it fake 50 now yeah is it fake
forty percent can I
can I give a perspective on it yeah
so
um for some [__] reason I had this
weird
YouTube rabbit hole where I looked into
Jake the Snake Roberts because back in
1998 I saw a wrestling documentary that
featured him right I was more less
interested in it because of the Rock
yeah yeah yeah I think it was a lot of
him in it and you're just kind of forced
to sit through and I'm in eighth grade
whatever I watch it and
um he's just this sad like he's become
this alcoholic and he fell into so much
Despair and but he's still out there
wrestling drunk and all this then fast
forward holy [__] how many years like
when he went on Joe Rogan 20 years late
15 years later and he's sober and is
actually talking about what was going on
um and he his clear as day open about
how he was raped when he was a boy yeah
by his father
you know and he's open about it right
but through the other like interviews I
hear and not just Joe Rogan but he keeps
making
boy rape jokes
right and I think it's like a coping
mechanism yeah yeah for him because of
what happened to him that he's always
like dropping on this weird [__] up
joke about you know getting touched or
that [__] right and it's unsettling like
hey you know like
whatever but you understand right and
David Cho on his show chosho have you
seen that on FX no he opens up about his
sexual molestation too when he was a kid
and how he has borderline personality
disorder he talks about it on that show
and it developed because his parents
were so poor that they couldn't take
care of two boys so they sent him to
Korea to be raised by family member who
molested him the whole time he was there
right and he came back thinking Hugh he
was punished
he did this because he was bad like and
so he's been [__] up by that since
then so when I you hear the repeated
offenses of it
I might think an allude to [__] like
that like it's a coping mechanism for
him to say something [__] up and laugh
about it to deal with the reality of him
having to live with it that because
that's what people do you know we'll say
the most [__] up [__] yeah but I don't
know like I like that context I think
like the hard part that I'm struggling
with is the
um
he's a liar hmm
so I don't know what's true now yeah and
you guys know I've talked about I
[__]
and he's an admitted liar he talks about
how he lies yeah I need you guys to
understand like I know White Lies I know
people FIB on things I'm not talking
about that yeah I I [__] hate liars I
share the same sentiments you know like
it it's like a complex yeah it's the
honesty complex I mean like that why we
become so honest through here
because we're so anti-like just telling
[__] lies yeah I hate that too the
same I think while I was gone you talked
about how your dad had implanted that
into you that my dad did the same thing
yeah I could never [__] lie to him if
I ever lied about being [__] out of me
if I lied about anything I felt like
[__] yeah somebody asked me too recently
they go did that make you uh
oh edrick asked me he was like did that
make you a better liar I was like it
actually did it it made me scared I'm so
bad at Mafia because of that it made me
like Mariel knows it too she goes
like dude she goes I could see you like
trying to like you're trying to like
spare my feelings by lying but you're
such a bad [__] liar yeah I mean yeah
she goes just say how you feel I was
like oh thank God yeah because it feels
like the world is coming down on me yeah
like the whole world is watching I feel
the same you know what I mean I know
exactly how you feel my dad would like
hate it when I [__] lied up like
heart start to beat like Fast same for
me my dad's been gone for a while yeah
I'm feeling like looking over my
shoulders if I ever feel like I can't
like cheat on anything you know this is
what I'm talking about right the only
thing I've ever cheated on was my diet
that's it
only I can [__] on myself for that you
know and you know
like I said fibbing whatever fine right
but I'm talking about blatant [__]
lying right so now I hear him tell about
the story about like
I'm not taking away anything from him
but he's openly admitted that he's a
habitual [__] liar so how do I not
know that you just pulled that out of
your ass to save you from this thing
like I can't believe anything that he
[__] says yeah and like you know when
you talk about the the Jake the Jake The
Snake thing right
Jake The Snake is making these little
fibs and jokes that story he told wasn't
a joke yeah there wasn't it wasn't like
it's like oh I wish somebody would touch
my ass right now like those are jokes
you know what I mean this is him saying
in the story I told this girl to open
her mouth open your mouth yeah and then
I sh and I face [__] her I was like
talk
like
and you know like I said I understand
like the whole bystander effect when
that would happen right
but because I know myself I think if
somebody told that story in front of me
I think I would lose my [__] yeah the
context of him bringing up a story like
that at all wasn't because it was like a
joke but a regular thing they would do
is talk about their sex lives because
he's a major sector addict right and
even anyone that comes on the show they
have to talk about how they lost their
virginity or the weirdest things always
always around center around sex right to
the point where like I put it on and
it'd be the podcast I'd sleep to or
whatever
and this one Dan was living with this
was at 904 right yeah yeah he said he
came to the room because he had to guess
on me but I was sleeping right but DVD
ASA was on the next morning he was like
bro what the [__] are you listening I'm
like what he's I was like oh David it's
[__] up right he's like yeah dude like
it's some [__] up [__] but it's
because like literally the alternate
title to that podcast was KGB Koreans
gone bad right it was his anti good
Korean just say [__] up things until
[__] up stories and talk about how he
gets laid all the [__] time that
story like by that point I think I had
stopped listening around 2013 so that
story came out a year later so I even
never got to hear it live yeah yeah yeah
until like this past month was a reason
his thing got canceled that that shot
everything down after that yeah oh [__]
I'd already just stopped listening to it
because it was like a lot it was it was
getting more and more ridiculous and I
felt like you didn't you don't have to
like make it more crazy you know
when I look at
just just to give you guys like uh just
a prefaces I I really liked beef right
um I have I still have two more episodes
and I really like it right now like it's
everything I love it too it's it's like
everything that we've talked about on
this podcast that was put onto a TV show
yeah you know what I mean what makes us
yes it's so
culture it defines us as korean-american
Millennials yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway
yeah yeah it it reminded me a lot of
like what me and Justin did with [__]
yeah yeah what I mean had a lot of
similar [__] tropes yeah and it was
very familiar and in a good way you know
and they could expand on like what ten
episodes you know so it was like damn
this is really nice it's like stuff that
I strive for which I really really liked
you know for Steven Yoon
I could understand why he's getting some
heat for this because it's like you knew
about this right and you took the chance
yeah you know for them the thing is like
you know he's he's a fabricated story
and he's better he's getting help
cool but you took the risk on that you
know what I mean
um because you could verbally say that
it's a fabricated story but Steven noon
himself doesn't even [__] know yeah
like you don't know if it's fabricated
or not you don't [__] know none of us
do he says he's a liar he says you don't
know what he's told that was true or not
none of us really do now yeah so I can
understand why people are upset at him
you know I get it I I 100 get it like
I'm not judging him I don't know his
personal relationship that he has with
David chill but they are close yeah
right
um I've seen them together on podcasts
before they they hang out they kick it
or whatever and even like how David Cho
got this role was he called him up and
said hey have you ever tried acting
before yeah do you see yourself as an
actor right he goes okay well you're
just gonna play an angry hung he goes
okay cool I can do that which by the way
I auditioned for this role yeah which
was [__] ridiculous because I'm
supposed to pay a 50 year old yeah
damn right because when I read the the
log line I auditioned for it it went
really well I loved it and then they're
like oh David Cho got it okay why the
[__] am I auditioning for this but then
I heard that on on the Rogan podcast
where David Cho was saying like it
wasn't written for him but then they
took a step back and realized it is him
yeah it's David show if you knew David
Cho from 10 years ago at the height of
his mental illness that's and you watch
beef that's who he was he couldn't
control his anger yeah and his loudness
and his addiction like
um his sex addition was was off the
walls like uh yeah so that's what I mean
he was all he had was just stories about
sex and yeah yeah [__] up [__] that he
did I mean because he he hitchhiked all
of America yeah he went through the
Congo he uh he lives with baboon eating
people for for weeks you know he has
amazing amazing Stories and then he has
this you know yeah where it's like
yeah I saw this roll and then when I was
watching him and I was like that's a
good cast you know like for him like I'm
aside from everything else like he that
was that's him that's him you know what
I mean like this is 100 makes sense also
I'm [__] 35. yeah
you know but when I was reading this
role I was like oh angry Korean hyung
I've been around all those guys my whole
life like this this is easy work but
then when I saw him play I was like okay
this is this is not it for me and also
once again I'm [__] 15 younger like
there's no I'm supposed to play like the
young of Steven Yeun like yeah it's like
the same age yeah like when he's a
little older he's older than me he's
like my age yeah yeah he's like I think
he's he's older than you I think I think
he's like 39 40. Oh okay okay he's like
40 now yeah so I'm like okay I was like
should be his like young that went to
jail I'm like this is not going to
[__] work but then I can't like I
look at the role too like who else could
play it I don't know it was kind of
David Joe that's about it that's him
yeah at the same time like when you
watch that you know people that you grew
up with just like that then just like
that too exactly right yeah we all know
somebody like that yeah man and
I I think you know people may might want
to take this with a grain of salt like
when I hear Steven you kind of laugh
awkwardly in that yeah like I didn't
when even when David Cho was talking
about this weird like scenario I
actually didn't know what the [__] he
was talking about you know so I could
imagine Stephen Yoon just being in his
podcast mode and just laughing along and
then being like Oh wait what did he say
do you know what I mean it happens a lot
it happens a lot on this podcast when
you guys come on they don't know what
the [__] they're saying or they go was
this podcast good I didn't know what I
was saying yeah so I I you get caught
like a deer in headlights like what was
he supposed to do kind of thing I think
you know the whole thing with hindsight
too about what somebody should have done
and could have done would have done it
happened
and I don't want to be angry at him for
for that like I don't know that they've
apologized in a sense right I don't know
what the if it was an apology it wasn't
really it was an excuse it was an excuse
right like they they didn't do I don't
think that's one of those things where
they're saying like I shouldn't have to
apologize which I get it like
you're casting somebody in it he fit the
[__] role yeah and he's saying it
it's his friend and he's saying that
it's a made-up story he's obviously
going to take the side of his friend and
believe his friend yeah
um for us as an audience
we don't know him like that yeah right
and we're only taking it from the person
that he shows us to be but then once
again it's too much back and forth of
this was a lie oh but this part is true
this is now your credibility as a human
being is [__] gone yeah like you have
no [__] credit this is why I [__]
hate liars yeah you are not a credible
person now I don't believe anything that
you say you know what I mean I think I
think that's what he wants too though in
a weird sick way like knowing his
character because he's
so chaotic and I think the shitty thing
about anthropology was like like
everything is an extension of my art but
[__] you dog you're [__] your art dog
you [__] butthole sweaters relax
[__] relax guy you know what I mean
yeah like that's the most [__] bougie
stupid [__] everything's an extension of
my art shut the [__] up yeah just be
like dog I was I was in a mental
institution I lost my [__] mind I was
afraid that I couldn't
um one of my past stories like my my
personality was tied to this [__]
podcast and I felt I was gonna lose
viewers so I just kept lying like a
piece of [__] that's a [__] apology
that makes more sense that makes more
sense just say that don't say [__]
this is an extension of my [__] art
[__] that apology say it I like how it
is I was I lost my [__] mind I was
locked up for three years in a mental
mental institution I've been trying to
work on this and this [__] [__]
haunts me because I'm stupid [__] that I
[__] said and I shouldn't have said
it because I was so addicted to wanting
to tell people crazy stories because
that's how I felt valued he was also
saying at the time like he was addicted
to self-destruction like because he's a
gambler right gambling whether he won or
lost he was addicted to the gamble so
even him saying like he was at a
Crossroads and he chose to deal with the
pain later and it was just like then you
knew what was coming like you had the
foresight to see that this was wrong
like yeah and then you told the story
too yeah about it right so either way
you like I said you know
and I see this a lot too where when I
see online apologies like there are
certain things that if you don't feel
like you should have to apologize for
just don't apologize for [__] things
will die down and [__] move on or if
you are going to apologize just [__]
apologize like [__] your PRP your PR
team doesn't know [__] like it's it's an
it's 2023 now
right like the way we apologize people
can see through that face should people
can see PR apologies from a mile away
right yeah I apologize for the actions
of the people I could you talk like that
you don't talk like that you don't sound
like that right but I really [__] up I
got caught up in the hype I don't know
what the [__] I was saying like next
time I'll make sure that I you know I
kind of check myself because this [__]
was [__] weird because I feel like if
somebody said that [__] to me I'd
probably be pissed too so I get it I
feel you on that and uh you guys can
choose to uh forgive me or not I'm just
gonna continue doing what I'm doing and
you know we'll see what's up that's
a regular ass [__] Pieology yeah he
mentioned something like that like he
can't stop the
the hate and the negative whatever
that's coming at him because it is what
it is but then all he can do is continue
to learn how to love and extend love
instead because I hate that apology too
though it's the most La way to say
things you know learn how to extend my
love shut the [__] up like people like
that every now and then you need to tell
them to shut the [__] up it's because
he's such a like his greatness is like
anyone has nobody tells him to shut the
[__] up like David nobody [__] cares
shut the [__] up you told this [__]
crazy story about you raping a [__]
woman and people were mortified you know
it might be because of his whatever
Factor he's at too that might be true
that nobody challenged and stepped up to
him to be like shut your [__] ass up
like seriously yeah like even like if I
put it in perspective like this right
like
Steven noon like you got you're a really
good friend of his right then like I
said you know dear and headlights being
in that situation I don't know what
their relationship was then right but if
you were his good friend you could have
told him to shut the [__] up it's like
what the [__] are you saying man yeah
like you're on this [__] podcast like
you even see me you've literally seen me
tell people to shut the [__] up like if
I tell people the people are out of the
line I've done it multiple times he's
[__] witnessed it like I do it all
the time right because if we're close
enough I should be able to say that to
you once for your sake and also for mine
and our friendship's sake you know when
you when you step out of [__] line
that's the [__] out of line yeah you
know and then
like I'm you know one of my friends
mentioned this too he goes I don't
understand why this isn't a bigger deal
like people make bigger deals about
[__] like simulu you know tweeting
some [__] yeah you know what I mean yeah
see Malu is not over here [__]
talking about him mouth [__] a girl
yeah forcefully you know what I mean and
it's absolutely nothing yeah you know
what I mean like I give that guy [__]
all the time because he's a dweeb but
he's not on this level yeah do you know
what I mean this is some [__] [__]
this is some [__] that we should all be
speaking out yeah like everybody's just
dead silent night you know this is the
other thing too
when people talk about somebody who who
for him who has built his importance in
the entertainment space and he's well
connected they're afraid that if they
say something bad about him that he will
take an opportunity away from them oh if
you speak about Dave what if you say
something about this you'll never work
in this [__] City again because David
Cho knows [__] Steven Yoon oh he
knows [__] Ali Wong and they're the
hottest thing right now what if they do
another series I want to be in that
series but if I say something they won't
cast me I know that's how you
[__] think but see for a
[__] C oh I must say semen Lube see
Malu yeah he doesn't have that power
right so you can openly talk about you
know his dweebiness about how weird he
is and all this other stuff and you
cannot like him which even then a lot of
people don't do but you will crucify him
more than you will this guy makes no
sense to me it doesn't make any sense to
me you can't you can't be silent like on
on this matter like I mean
look if this is a me too thing for sure
but then the the thing is the the whole
important factor on this is that nobody
has actually come out and to say
David Cho did this to me he said it said
it himself yeah yeah you know and for me
too at the point that's very true too
I'm looking at it at 35
000 feet in the air once again you know
when
Donald Trump he himself got caught
saying I grabbed him by the [__]
how many women came forward yeah yeah
yeah how many women and right now he is
in trial for a rape case from the 90s
you know for me too is like
um I was just like when this happened
2014 I was just waiting but there's got
to be tons of women because all he ever
talks about is how much sex he has with
so many women and how he gets home to
sleep with them and I was just sitting
and waiting for someone to come out and
say David chill rape me yeah yeah yeah
until that hap I guess again yeah and it
hasn't because I was waiting for that
because it's inevitable with the metoo
movement like this person would come out
and she's like admitting like he slept
with thousands of people but
they're not one yet so this is why I'm
reserved still you know for him like I'm
also like I said the whole
lie like that yeah you know what I mean
it's so specific down deep down
cerebrally okay so here's my other next
Theory yeah
he talked about for all the shows he's
been on like even Star Wars
um he was on the first season of
Mandalorian it was a quick one second
two second shot right I don't even
remember him being in metal right no it
was a two second shot oh right at some
space casino and he's screaming and
yelling right he said that
what he realized like uh for his acting
sense whatever he's not a trained actor
or anything but because of the way his
brain works he's a method actor
so he learned hatis you know what Jabba
the Hutt speaks yeah she learned the
whole language to say a line to
basically hey [__] him up or whatever
and then even John Favre was like what
are you doing
what are you doing man I just said
you're just gonna I'll put you in a shot
you know because David Cho did graffiti
for for the show but then so that's what
he was saying that he's a method actor
so for this rolling beef he read the
script all through it and then he had to
understand why his character would make
these decisions and he wrote up this
entire backstory for himself right and
and then he said after they rap filming
he checked himself into a mental
hospital because he lost his mind
because he was in his method acting and
trying to be this character right
and so that much that's my theory about
when you're asking how can you say
something like this in such detail yeah
I think it's because for his show DVD
girl curly hair
a strand of hair came down right that is
so so specific yeah you know because now
too like because he's such a habitual
liar
he says he checked himself to a mental
hospital I want to see papers now
because like I do you know what I mean
yeah because now you can't believe
anything anything now I don't believe
anything he says now I can only just put
it into context and the thing is like or
and just hypothesize but not know
whether it's true or not yeah because
stuff like that if he tells stories like
okay well you know back in the day like
this that's whatever a mental hospital
has records yeah
and he's used that multiple times he's
been like multiple times show us the
[__] records
right I want to see the public records
that or the I want to see the records
that you make public saying like look
this is the time that I checked in this
is what I did after the film because now
I don't believe anything that you
[__] say like you have lost your
credibility as an artist as a human
being to me a hundred percent like it
just it sucks it sucks you know dude
even the clip where he's out and he's
lost in the Congo if you've seen that
clip on Rogan oh yeah he says oh which
version of the story should I tell
why can't I tell you the clean version
right as if the other version is that he
killed his travel partner or something
you know yeah but then he just goes into
story of okay he ended up finding the
village yeah but then apparently there's
some other nefarious version of the
story you know so that's another thing
about him being a Storyteller is him
leaving this weird mysterious end to it
to not know is this story [__] true
or not yeah like yeah you know it's like
like put himself in a very weird
position right he's self-destructive and
chaotic he likes making people [__]
wonder and not know what the truth is
and it's a weird self-destructive thing
that he does dude we'll be telling
stories on this podcast where it's like
oh we're at a bar and I was talking [__]
about they're like fake I'm like that's
fake
it's interesting that happened to me
yeah and like this guy here it's like
you know
I don't know it's something about that
[__] it's like even the idea that he's
stealing his friend's stories and using
it for his own gay I hate that [__] too
so and also because he holds himself in
such a high regard as an artist
it it nothing is making sense to me like
my brain is [__] like frazzled right
now okay so you want me to frazzle it
one more time you know that dope ass
mural at Lacy of Bourdain yeah yeah yeah
first week
you could see it was an actual picture
because the end product you could see
it's his style of just splash colors and
all that [__] right but in the beginning
the first week it was a legit portrait
of ordain yeah on the mural right but it
wasn't David Cho painting it it was just
some white girl I got there and she was
painting a portrait of Bourdain and then
he came in with the cameras and did all
of his work on it
are you [__] kidding me right now no
no who was the girl just some I think it
was a girl who lives at Lacey I don't
know she got commissioned and he put his
[__] on it and then he put his [__] on
top and then it was a David Cho a piece
of work
did he ever give her credit
oh I don't know so he I thought it was
for the show or some CNN piece or
something I never saw it anywhere it
never aired it it was just I thought
that was just the David Cho piece that
it's the what you're seeing on top of
the board name you're a [__] fraud
man
I don't know man like why is every
[__] David celebrity pissing me off
right maybe because he has my first name
and he's Korean that is getting under my
[__] skin yeah first David chain is
stupid
[__] and a shitty ass [__]
instant noodles that he keeps pushing on
us yeah have you had those
no I'll give it to you and then you'll
throw up it's so bad
I mean then I was a huge David Cho fan
too and this is like one of those Bill
Cosby things where I'm like [__] dude
like like you went you went like so far
over the edge there's so many accounts
of of like
there's so many [__] like strikes for
him right now because the thing that
admonishes him from this heinous act now
makes him a [__] fraud as an artist
yeah like you're a [__] fraud you're
worthless
he's his value is zero to me now not
only are you like okay cool I'm so glad
I hope and I pray to God that you lied
because I'm hoping that there was isn't
a girl who got [__] face [__] by
you by force I'm I pray to God you're
[__] lying because and then there's
in a victim right
now the other side of this is that you
are a worthless [__] artist
[Laughter]
the other that's the other side you're
worthless everything you do is a [__]
lie
well it's like yeah I'm sure the value
of his own art now is like tanking is I
got a Dave Cho piece
you [__] steal stories you lie about
[__] your [__] mural outside that I
saw that I really [__] thought was
dope but somebody else is like to use
splatter paint on it you [__] fraud
I just found out that Santa Claus isn't
real dude just like everything's just
like oh [__] this
for me I'm bringing up man we gotta
bring it we're trying to
trying to do good you killed my Korean I
feel deceived because you're like out
there for us and when this [__] goes out
like
he's like
you're putting we've we all feel this
like bro like you were the Forefront for
us because of how much coin Pride he has
too yeah it's like but we're not like no
I don't don't represent us anymore you
[__] fraud like man dude like I
I just I wish this never happened
my whole life
I thought this fat man came down a
[__] chimney yeah gave me ate my
[__] cookies and milk and then left
me gifts right I'm not saying that I
looked up to David Cho right it's just
not what you thought it was it's just
not who I thought you know he was very
fascinating to me like oh this guy
really is about his [__] and I think
that's why I respect like hearing his
stories about him going to the Congo
doing all the stuff like this guy is
nuts but he's about his [__] and he's
impulsive as [__] yeah there's something
to admire about this and once again I
don't know too much about the DVD
awesome stuff so I don't know any of his
other stories that he told yeah I mean
like
it basically their crazy stories are
fascinating stories because he is a hell
of a Storyteller you know yes very good
story but then it would go to a point
where like there there was a point where
I stopped listening because I was like
what is this [__] you know what does
this become because it was just so weird
like he was he was like pressuring his
guests or people on the show to like
tell their stories about like this
happened to them when they were whatever
when them they're having sex or some
[__] right and then one person had to
leave the show and quit her job because
her co-workers found out she was on this
podcast and she talked about a story
about how she gave a five hour [__]
you know and then she just never
appeared again and that's the kind of
[__] it was doing to the people around
him this is something Yoshi was saying
on his podcast that yeah everybody he
was meeting he didn't he has to realize
he was ruining their lives by making
them expose themselves on this podcast
which people aren't like they're not
ready for but he is self-destructive but
he was saying that's Entertainment and
saying you guys have to be
self-destructive too with me
you know and that was [__] up all the
relationships around him everybody
around him yeah he did this to himself
yeah so like you know when we talk about
this too and like now we're going to
talk about beef in another episode where
we will break it down
but then it's like the whole argument of
separating the art from the artist right
now look David Cho was in the show it's
not his show right once again to iterate
that
you know but I think for us too like
we're going to start looking at the show
objectively with how we feel about it
and then like
like how will you watch it now with this
David Cho information
I mean like the reason why I haven't
finished up was because that [__] was so
disturbing to me you know mind you I
like that show a lot you know I think
it's dope right it's everything that I
wanted to do yeah right
[Music]
um
and it's executed very well
but it's very seldom that you'll ever
see me like stop watching something
because looking at somebody's face is
pissing me off yeah like
watching his face on the show gets me
mad now you know what I mean like it's
pissing me off wait for those last two
episodes yeah but now it's probably
gonna make the show even better now
because there's more context so it's
like oh I can see why this character fit
him so [__] well yeah but you know
when I when I saw him you know as a
korean-american like
you know watching beef
it makes sense to me yeah because I know
I've seen these people I mean every
character on that show we know them and
we're pieces of us yeah we see ourselves
in the show you listen to all these
podcasts you'll see beef and everything
yeah you know what I mean like apart me
when I saw the show I was like I could
have done this
yeah something like this you know but um
it's just done really well I mean I am
going to finish it because I have to
because obviously like it's a really
good show and I don't want to take away
from the other people who um created the
show obviously Steven Yoon was a part of
it I don't think he wrote it it was a
Korean guy that wrote it yeah so there's
a there's a hard line though with the
idea of separating art from artists like
I brought it up before the movie
Chinatown from the 70s starring Jack
Nicholson
I think it's one of the greatest movies
ever made the director
is
what's his name Roman Polanski
he raped the 14 year old
yeah and he's been in France ever since
he can't come back to America holy [__]
so that's what happened but guess what
happened to him in like 2004 2005 when
Academy Award for best director for his
movie The Pianist
you know but he couldn't be there to
pick it up yeah and then
in the past few years they bring that up
the fact that the academy awarded him
for the best director knowing that he's
a rapist yeah 14 year old rapist
everybody knows this about him
you know
and then they but they still brought
into the academy and awarded him and
gave him his flowers for that even
though he wasn't there now is that wrong
too
right it's it's so hard like
listen there's a big reason why I just
um
Hollywood like I really don't [__]
like Hollywood it's there's something
wrong about this whole thing right and
not just Hollywood now it's YouTube
Instagram [__] celebrities there's
something wrong with everything right
like
there's a reason why these [__] red
pill videos are coming up now right
it's swung so far this way and now
people are coming over here to drag you
guys back this way you know what I mean
like there's the sense of morality is
so hyper subjective now yeah right like
it people are kind of losing their sense
of what's right and wrong because the
thing is it's like you could excuse
anything by just saying like well that's
just how you feel right and look I've
just like I said we could I encapsulate
things like within comedy right I talk
about the reasons why and I can go
through it
you know when I when
it's very hard for me to s in that type
of case right because I didn't even know
that [__] I actually didn't know that at
all
um
like you give an award to a man who's
like a known [__] on the run on the
Run rapist that should be a hard line
there yeah that's a hard [__] line I
don't give a [__] what you create dude I
I could literally care [__] less and
you want to hear another little shitty
stain he was in [__] Rush Hour three
he was the Chief Inspector the French
inspector oh for real yeah and they
punch him at the end at the Eiffel Tower
that's him that's Roman Polanski what
the [__] they put him in that movie and
it's like I'm watching it too like what
the [__] Roman Pulaski why you gotta
ruin the rush hour franchise now
what the [__]
what is that
what kind of Jackie Chan doesn't know
[__] but it's like what the [__] yeah
like what is this right that's what I'm
saying like there was a whole Committee
of Hollywood stars of people in the
academy who signed this letter of
something to the government like we
should allow our own plansky to come
home or some [__] right and it's like no
no you guys a bunch of like apparently
Natalie Portman like signed her name to
it too like a bunch of Hollywood yeah
bring him home so we can put him in
[__] jail yeah but no they were
saying like you know it's like yo this
guy never face Justice you know wait
what what is the objective of them
saying bring him home so he could allow
to live his life
[__] no it's [__] twisted are these
people [__] crazy are you living in a
[__] bubble like do you think people
in Hollywood are like man I miss Roman
he was a cool guy
she needs to keep making movies because
he does make good [__] movies yeah
but the problem is like do you want to
work with this guy right the best yeah
like this is what I'm saying like people
in Hollywood they're [__] their
perception and view of the world is
simply based around what they can take
from that's it they only speak up about
things if it affects their job that's it
that's why when I see celebrities talk
about social justice shut the [__] up
you don't care about anything unless it
affects your job you do not [__] care
you want a pat like for example this is
the weirdest thing so like John
Leguizamo was getting [__] because he
was talking about you know Latin
representation in the Super Mario movie
right this three this [__] Japanese
game right yeah a Japanese game about
two Italian plumbers that live in the
summer It's like because you were
miscast as Luigi like how many movies
did he play in Italian gangster when
he's Latin he's like is right I don't
understand what he's talking about he's
going on this people are [__] on him
right and guess what he does and I'm not
saying like I said this is not me
talking about my opinions about this
subject at all but I understand why he
did this and it's just for his selfish
purpose he just goes he puts out the
statement he goes
I believe in all trans people and people
are like yeah yeah so he uses this
trance movement to erase this other [__]
that he did you know what I mean and
like I said this is not my opinion about
you know transl this is not that at all
I'm just saying I understand his chess
move yeah you know what I mean yeah and
once again I love John Leguizamo or I
used to you know I just don't [__]
after yeah what the [__] is he doing
right once again once you get into this
system and you're around other people
who kind of gas you up and and just
they're like-minded in the sense of all
the worst qualities possible you start
to believe in your own [__] [__]
there's nobody talking to you that's
down to earth like what the [__] are you
talking about man what are you saying
you sound [__] dumb dude
you know what I mean and you know why
because I know what this feels like you
do a big project and then you go to
these [__] mixers you talk to these
producers these casting people these
Executives you're laughing at all the
jokes you're shaking [__] hands right
and you feel like you're part of this
club the special system and then you
start feeding into it they start
laughing at everything that you're
saying you start laughing at everything
that they're saying right and then you
start to feel like you're [__]
special
in this moment when you're around other
people who at the drop of a hat can
change your [__] life you start
agreeing with these people you become
the most agreeable person ever yeah it's
like hey we're supporting Roman Polanski
you in or out yeah and now what these
these [__] artists are are an artist
actors are in the [__] Crossroads you
know to have to choose and it's like
who's making these [__] rules this is
why there are certain actors I'm not
saying this is every [__] actor right
yeah but I understand why this lull of
Hollywood is hard to escape from it's
hard to be better than because you just
kind of get hypnotized by it no right
which is why I was never liked at those
things people would look at me and I
wouldn't laugh and I'm like what the
[__] are you laughing at me
it felt like the sunken Place yeah I
felt it like it legit felt like the
sunken place and they they touch on that
in beef the whole thing with
um you know Amy Laos Ali Wong's
character is how she has to look at
everybody and smile yeah all the time
right and it's too a [__] point for
us though we're just like don't we don't
have to [__] [__] like I'm not
gonna [__] smile at the horseshit
yeah like I don't understand why
everybody's laughing I don't know why
everybody's like and I like so I I
brought
so it was me and Khalif at this ABC
mixer event right and then
um
it was like who's who's everybody was
there talking to people chopping it up
I'm laughing whatever whatnot and then
I could literally feel my like Soul
being eaten up like it felt like this
person inside of me was dying right
right and I had to mentally prepare
myself for mixers like that yeah and the
moment we stepped out my smile went away
and the cliff was like Hey I'm proud of
you man like you did it right I wasn't
suck the energy out of you suck the life
force and I wasn't proud of myself I
hated I hated myself I [__] hated
myself it was so hard and so fake to be
it's so fake it's so it's just to be a
liar yeah you know
how come we can't just go in there and
be like hey who are you
how come I can't say that yeah how come
I can't walk up to him be like I don't
know who you are uh what is this what
you do yeah that's cool that's dope
that's dope have a regular conversation
no I have to laugh and I have to laugh a
lot everything that you say is hilarious
right but if I don't do that oh this guy
he's he's not a team player it's like no
I'm a normal person and I don't know who
you are
you know that's one thing I'm always
going to be salty about was just how
they kind of force you to be something
that you and mind you there are certain
casting directors that really [__]
they still love me now that's why they
send me I'm not signed to an agency but
they always send me auditions yeah and
the reason why is because they remember
me and there are certain casting
directors that are so [__] dope at
what they do and they're so cool that
they actually appreciated my
authenticity and I didn't know what they
were talking about so I'll give you I'll
give you this example
it's a cast instructor that I walked in
to and um it was a general meeting and I
showed up in a tank top shorts and
flip-flops and I sat down and I was
talking and then we were chopping it up
and I was like hey I'll be honest with
you I don't know what a general meeting
is yeah I don't even know why you're
talking to me but if you'd mind like can
I ask you like I want I like I don't
know anything about your job and I just
started asking her questions about her
job and then we were talking for like 40
minutes because the meeting was supposed
to only be like 10 or 15 minutes yeah
but I'm so curious about her job and
what she does like how what the
selection process is like what they look
for like how this whole thing works
and then
later on like we met up again
um I forgot where the [__] it was at but
it was like we're just you know chopping
it up and she goes I just want to let
you know like that meeting was very
refreshing I was like what do you mean
she goes like it was very bold of you to
come in like shorts and flip-flops I was
like was I supposed to dress up oops
dude she started busting up laughing she
goes this is what I'm talking about like
she goes sometimes when people come into
this office and you know they're doing
good things they smell of desperation
and she goes I could tell like you could
take her sleeping
you literally just came in to ask me
what I do for a job and it was nice to
be able to talk about myself and you
know you were asking really good
questions which most people don't like
they're just sitting here just kind of
trying to impress me yeah and it was
very nice love me yeah please accept me
yeah and then there was another casting
like I this wasn't planned I wasn't
trying to be the antithesis of what
people want I just didn't know what the
[__] any of this stuff is yeah so one
time like so Vanessa if you guys
remember she was my assistant at the
time she wanted to go into casting so I
remember I was like can I brought my
assistant
um can she ask you questions
Vanessa starts asking um it was two
casting directors questions about their
job and whatever whatnot and they also
remember that too they go that was the
weirdest general meeting I've ever had
I've never had somebody bring in their
assistant to ask them questions about my
job I think if you have the confidence
in yourself to be yourself
people can
people can sense that and feel yeah
because we're just talking about how
much being fake [__] irks us yeah to
the edge like that's a [__] knocking
knot in my neck but like
uh so I used to have a mullet
uh it was pretty crazy like and I had
bleached the end of it to wrap the tail
and then uh I had this internship or an
interview for this job offer as an
intern like and I just came in with the
mullet and I was just like yeah I can do
this this and then here's my demo reel
and then I got hired you know and then I
started making content for you know
Blockbuster when you go in I don't know
if you guys remember Blockbuster but
there'd be TVs and they're playing a
program yeah yeah yeah and then be like
some you know like hey welcome to
Blockbuster this month's new releases oh
yeah yeah trailers and stuff and then be
like hey this song's featured in this
movie and I play a music video so I used
to do that kind of [__] and after a
while being comfortable there yeah the
the people who hired me later told me
we're like you know we're really glad
you're here like well thank you you know
and it's like yeah when you came in with
the interview and you left we were just
like
that guy has a mullet he has to work
here
it's like that's just who he is you know
some people are looking for that kind of
energy like yeah I know if you're
familiar with Enoch Lin uh he was a
music singer yeah lead singer of like
Burning Tree Project Fike
his life story is crazy yeah he's he
only told me a little bit about it when
we were like when I think I don't think
he was drinking but I was drinking you
got to get him here dude yeah yeah his
life story nuts but it's the same like
you know he went out to just get a
corporate job for a minute and just his
look is so crazy his hair is like I have
to hear his tatted up and all that [__]
he looks [__] angry all the time
nicest dude ever nicest dude ever super
inspirational by the way but in his job
interview they were like so why should
you work here instead of the other
people waiting in the lobby and he said
look at them
do you want to work with a bunch of
squares or do you want to work with me
that's what he said
and they hired him you know so funny
it's like that's the kind of Truth and
confidence like you walk with like
people can smell that fake kind of
confidence when it's like you're an
[__] dude you know it's it it's so
apparent all the time yeah and you know
I kind of get off on this [__] it's like
when those [__]
fraudulent [__] I know when
they talk about me to other people like
oh this guy David he's an [__] it's
like I'm not an [__] I'm normal and
you forgot what it was like to be around
a normal person the truth is David
doesn't play the game yeah say that yeah
it's like you like I looked at you like
you were insane because you were acting
like a crazy person
you know yeah this is your fault David
yeah it's like hey how's it going it's
like what are you getting coffee it's
like I can't get coffee that should make
me go crazy
and I'm like
I was like what the [__] was that yeah
like that wasn't funny I'll just tell
you this caffeine affects me why are you
laughing you know how I get yeah it's
like that kind of [__] like I don't know
you like the cops like the sunken Place
yeah and it's weird I just don't like it
I will always say that I'm so grateful
that I get to choose my own path you
know like this podcast you know even
creating the stupid little jokes on
Instagram and these videos that go viral
for a second it's great because I got to
do it with my own needs yeah and that's
what I mean by when I when I create this
content it's the idea that I created
something that made somebody laugh that
makes me very happy yeah you know yeah
the the that's the part that kind of
gives me a really good high it's like
damn somebody laughed because of this
like they were scrolling by they looked
at it and I made their day better yeah
because for me as a kid a lot of people
don't understand it's like I chose
comedy over music because of the [__]
feeling I had making somebody laugh yeah
like just in tears laughing like when
you do stand-up right and is the time
that when I was really in love with it
I remember just doing stand-up and the
feeling that I would get before you know
I would do music and people would cheer
me on and I feel like people were
praising me because I had a good voice
right but then when I did stand up and I
made somebody laugh
I felt like they were praising me
because I made their day better you know
and that was a good feeling that's what
comedy is you know so what you know just
to wrap it back to when I saw Jordan do
that joke like if it was her being
mean-spirited about that stuff right I
wouldn't have laughed but it was her
trying to make light of something you
know make some humorous that you weren't
supposed to find humorous to get that
insight about it like oh this is
hilarious right
so I don't think it was punching down
yeah you know a lot of people like to
say but
you know like the whole David Cho thing
like just to wrap this up uh before we
end this episode it's like
I just don't know what's true right
right so he kind of maybe I'm also
frustrated because he's put me in limbo
you know I can't I can't even serve my
own sense of justice down because I
don't know what the [__] is real and
that's that's him
for him to [__] with people that way too
oh I'm just realizing how much it hurts
him
beat his ass for this a weird [__]
way of looking at the world to be like
chaotic like it's like the Joker it's
just chaos he's the Joker dude yeah it's
just chaos he's [__] with me that's
also because he's Korean that is correct
he's Korean he has my [__] name and
he has a quality about himself that I
hate the most
you know it's like this quality that you
don't want to see in yourself yeah right
and David Cho rides with David so I hate
it so much yeah hey David so what do you
think of David Cho and people won't keep
asking about David Cho like you you know
him right you know him right it's like
no no we don't
they're all breaking my hearts Man David
Choi please don't [__] up it's like no
he's not no I love him he's making like
children's music he feels like he's
getting his stride now where he's he's
found like his importance again yeah man
which is dope and by the way children's
Beauty make money David keep it up the
algorithm favors children's content
gonna make the next baby shark bro I
hope so dude [__] David I hope you
bank it man but uh that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast
um hope you guys enjoyed this episode
uh hope you took away something from
this once again there was no excusing
his behavior but once again it's just a
lot of context for you guys to figure
out how you feel about it right
um once again we we talk about this
everybody lies
everybody makes White Lies We FIB we
kind of aggrandize stories here and
there my issue with this is the fact
that he just what the this this is
heinous like it's [__] heinous yeah
um we will do a review of beef
um the next time
uh we just wanted to kind of wrap this
up on this episode so we can get this
out the way so we could talk about beef
openly yeah it's going to re-watch it
I'm gonna re-watch it again so we can go
ahead and kind of give like a better
analysis of this it is a lot to unpack
10 episodes and it's a little more
personal because we are Korean Americans
and reflects on a lot of the stories
it'll be a long one yeah talk about this
podcast so you could catch Ed at edpark
B BP talk too much
[Laughter]
foreign
I know we're trying to wrap it up but
did you hear where Lululemon got its
name from no the [__] founder of the
company thought it'd be funny if for
Asians to try to pronounce it that's
[__] hilarious
[Laughter]
this episode
I know that's supposed to be really I
needed to inform that but I just heard
that I know that's supposed to be
offensive but [__] what a hard play yeah
what a [__] troll
my mom loves it too but it's like you
got her [__]
it's like when Korean people say Vivian
it makes me laugh so hard so why did you
name your kids
is
uh you can catch Ed at Ed Park v p uh
Bible Study Bible I keep saying
breakfast at Momos because Momo sounds
like a dope ass place to eat it is okay
it was it's it's no longer oh okay Bible
study at Momos
um you can catch genius brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m
um secret society is my uh fashion
Basics clothing line uh we are growing
fast now
um thank you guys for supporting us uh
our spring summer launch is coming soon
and then we have a uh a little anime
inspired piece coming out that's gonna
be [__] dope make sure that you cop
that it's going to be pre-orders uh we
will see you all next time peace peace